[Music]
welcome back to on the record where we
talk about the article
whoa and the article is what will that
be like
i don't know we've never done it where
we could talk about whatever we want as
long as it
doesn't break any rules on youtube
doesn't offend anybody doesn't offend
anyone
make us get cancelled or you know
doesn't
really mess with the algorithm does it
make people think too much doesn't yeah
and then we just kind of all laugh
together i don't like thinking too much
sounds like a good show by the way
what's the wing place called that saved
their lunch today
that was really good right you know i
heard that they're open from 11 to 4.
you can order it now
just saying w i n g c-h-i-x
if you guys want to know what it is
yummy yummy they literally saved our
lunch today because they came and
our lunch didn't come so it was perfect
and it was good great very very true if
you like japanese-style
uh tepesaki wings and if you've never
tried them
is more importantly like myself they're
excellent
thank you absolutely all right so in
this article we are going to be talking
about
uh qatar the country cutter
cutter as a cutter if you are a sergeant
in the military you go
cutter that's what storm and norman
schwarzkopf said in uh
in the bush the first bush
administration cutter we're going to
burn the [ __ ] out of cut
we're going to go to cutter why is it so
fun to say like that could or
i don't know i don't know but it was was
it desert storm
yeah okay the first well that we didn't
attack them but it was part of the whole
situation yeah i see
all right so this story takes place in
qatar and
uh at the airport in doha i hope i'm
pronouncing that
probably oklahoma you've been a guitar
no but i know it's doha
it's the capital how do you know these
things i don't know
i don't i don't know for sure but i but
i i think have you heard it somewhere or
did you read it and then i heard it my
right hand to god doha is the capital of
cutter
thank you is it i only know because
uh can went there to perform dances
for the military there no i see he's a
part of a dance crew
and in the military gets entertainment
they do actually
like standard comedians out there wwe
wrestlers pretty cool
i'm sure they loved it when the guys
danced too
poor can all right so um
something terrible happened at the
airport uh
staff at the airport found a baby a
newborn baby
stuffed into a trash can at in one of
the bathrooms at the airport
but it lived it lived
and it's okay okay all right but i
thought it was gonna be like a cute
story like
there was a cute little basket like you
know how they leave them at the fire
station and stuff oh yeah this is not
one of those this is the uh
stuff it in the trash can cover it with
some paper towels and uh
leave it be sad do they not understand
how genetics
and science and biology works i don't
know if they're gonna no one's gonna
catch me we're gonna find yeah they're
gonna find the mother
we're gonna find the father wait uh this
was on base
uh this is at the airport oh the airport
it's at the airport
and uh so that's that's the the happy
part i guess like the the
the part that um that the baby got
babies the baby was saved yes they did
not die
so someone was transferring on a
vacation
yeah pushed the baby out and left it
there are you saying they weren't
going to cutter for vacation no one goes
to cutter for me
okay okay all right and so then i just
like to imagine that someone was going
they're connecting yeah or they they
this is
this is how uh pregnancy works in my
mind
is like they just had a wild night in
spain
and they're like i need to go back to um
vietnam or whatever right and then they
stop in the middle of
you know what i like to think is that
they gave birth on the flight
to cutter yeah gonna do connection but
they the trash cans are so small in the
bathroom that they're like
[ __ ] can't get the baby in here and
so they're like okay i'll just take it
back to my seat and i'm like oh i just
have a baby it's great
and then when they get there they're
like they dump it in the bigger trash
can then they go home to tyler
yeah oh that's a great scenario or a
great uh
no it's not it's horrible it's horrible
but i mean that's a good assumption
that's my assumption yes that's a great
assumption how about that i'm gonna keep
making him flip-flop this whole episode
oh no stop
okay here we go i'm gonna plow through
this you do know the trash kids are very
small in the bathrooms right they're
very small in the bathroom they're so
they're not
they can barely get the paper towel in
there they're big they're very big by
the end of every flight
it is stuck with paper towels because
there's so many people on the plane you
could never get a baby in there geo even
if it's brand new
if you try really hard
all right so i don't once the airport
caught wind of the baby
they instantly were trying to find the
person responsible
now they stopped 10 flights they
actually
10 flights they grounded them and they
took uh
well on one one of these flights they
actually took 18 women off this flight
there's no men no men why not
because men can't have babies oh sorry
maybe go it's all right okay
thank you sorry i'm sorry it's okay wait
were they uh
they're trying to catch the lady that uh
gave birth they assumed that it was
gonna be the mother
that did this but maybe it wasn't a and
they don't say this
they assumed they were gonna catch the
person yeah they assumed that it was
the mother that did this what would they
know what do you mean
like just by stopping the women like
don't they have to like
see underneath the women to take off the
planes i
i have an assumption that maybe the baby
was a
a white baby because they among the
women that
uh that made it into this article they
did detail that it was two british women
and 13 australian
citizens that got pulled off these
planes
and what happened next is the terrifying
part oh my god did they
did they search all their vaginals yes
holy [ __ ] i brought ambulances onto the
tarmac
oh wow that's crazy and then they they
told these women to get onto the
ambulance are you hiding something in
there yeah well we get to hide i have a
lot of [ __ ] whatever you're hiding
ladies it's not a baby
yes uh so that secrets they're myself
how would you know
holy [ __ ] oh you wait because your
shit's all [ __ ] up and you're bleeding
and it's i mean you got to heal i mean i
mean like
how would you know unless they did it
because they did it by the way what is
i know so i mean like how would you
figure it out then if they don't see the
[ __ ]
how would you figure out they don't like
well how are you going to figure out
bloody bloody socks
yeah with bloody boy right because okay
so if
if if the like obvious way to check is
to see
right and if you can't see it then how
would you investigate it
if you can't get consent but are they
doing more than seeing is that but they
may not have asked for consent
they don't go into detail as a different
country they're doing yeah so you can do
whatever they want we did not ask for
consent
i mean i i i had an experience where
there
really wasn't much i could do when i was
in morocco not it's not
it's not the same oh no it's not that no
nothing like that but it's like they
is it a different country so yes abide
by their own yeah and their laws are
their laws and they took your drone i
mean they took my drone and like there
was nothing you could say
to you know even try to convince them to
work out anything else
or you want to go to jail exactly it's
like hey you listen to us now or i will
take you to jail like very black and
white
and so i like in this situation i'm sure
they might have approached it in a very
similar manner where it was like
we're searching your vagina whether you
like it or not if not you're going to
jail
and you're looking for drones they're
looking for drugs they're trying to
confiscate some drones exactly
we can make money off of them and um but
the demeanor is very black and white and
that's
that's my point and so then yeah um out
of the 10 flights that were grounded
they detailed one particular flight that
had 13 australian citizens and two
british women
that um were part of the search they
were ordered to take off their underwear
and then and i'm not too sure what else
they were doing but it almost feels like
did they catch the woman's
uh the ongoing investigation
and very neat tidy vaginas yes and maybe
their assumption that the woman was on
the flight might have been wrong in the
first place maybe
she could have been leaving into the
leading into the city yeah so that that
might be a dead end in and of itself but
now
uh qatar and and the airline
now they're in a new fiasco now yeah
the australian international exactly the
australian government's getting involved
now
and um and i think uk the uk
foreign commonwealth and development
office uh
that they said that we're providing
ongoing support to our two british women
uh and basically uh a lot of the women
are also you know just traumatized by
the whole situation
and um rightfully yes and so now
now would you like to see your vagina
please you could come come over here
that's such a shock they don't even tell
you what it what happened so even if
they pulled 12 women yeah even if
they're right in one woman out of 12
they got to look at
11 innocent vaginas fur
not all vaginas are innocent bro okay
true
i know yours is very guilty i've heard
you know wow this is so distressing
yeah crazy and then hopefully get that i
got the egbg's
you know what's weird is i'm assuming
that all airports
has good uh security cameras all that
and i'm like why don't they just play
back for the trashes
totally yeah who went into the bathroom
who came out done you literally see what
they're wearing
it's i mean yeah you can stop the
flights but before you go check some
[ __ ] out like why don't you just
play back the camera and go did you
think they were just trying to
like immediately just act well they
didn't do a good job
stupidest didn't even block the doors or
or check if they went
other ways sweet geo you think they
weren't trying to look at [ __ ] i think
that that's what they were trying to do
it was a complete abuse of happiness it
all happened
because they saw some fine ass girls
go into this one airplane 11 and there's
no baby and they're just like
hold on chief we gotta [ __ ] see their
[ __ ] that one
that one that
[Laughter]
crazy all of that cause some horny guys
wow exactly so then on monday uh today's
friday
australia's foreign ministry said uh
reports that had indicated the incident
was
beyond circumstances in which the women
could give free and informed consent
but it declined to label this whole
situation as in a sexual
sexual assault uh and now they're
waiting for the details from
qatari officials and um but then
obviously a lot of
uh opposition politicians what does that
even mean
but anyways other politicians in
australia are like the people who aren't
in power in australia they're like
you're this government's not sticking up
for the people that
got it they're they're calling a sexual
assault
and that you know basically there needs
to be reprimand and stuff like that and
now qatar is also saying like this is
not a you know the standard that you
know
our nation the nation goes by and that
this is definitely
you know appalling and just to take dna
samples if you're not trying to look at
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah it's 20 20.
i mean there's technology to back up
investigations exactly
like old school
[Laughter]
that's so gross man
[Music]
you